you had a religious upbringing I want my
parents are very conservative you know
sort of like my mom teaches Sunday
School and that was nauseous and angry
I'm still working on the face yeah that
really made me laugh anyway no but she
is she a serious person no no she has a
very funny dark sense of humor Anna
she's a prankster so like here's an
example like my dad liked to watch Birds
you know like look at birds they live
out in the country and no not Dwight's
farm not the beet farm I get that one
too no just make sure it's farms they
live on Schrute floor anyway such open
content for your thing mom my dad and my
mom would go to great lengths she would
buy fake Birds and then like get like
get wire and strap him under the tree
and then she would just wait like the
planning that went into it my dad would
be like hey we got three new Cardinals
they had moved in four hours these are
really realistic Birds it's not like
that's not well why is that kurtal have
a clock in the middle of it feathers and
everything you should strap him under
trees and then she got really into this
fake foot and she kept putting the fake
foot all over the houses scared the crap
out of us yes but it looks very like a
barefoot fake foot like a severed foot
like a severed foot and and I thought
okay I've moved out now right I'm I'm
not gonna have the foot thing anymore
then she mailed me the foot I got the
friend a box and then I thought okay now
we're done cuz I hid the foot we can't
even find it anymore yeah and then my
husband bought a fake bloody hand my
husband's gotten in on it it's like I
don't even react anymore I open the
fridge the other day and the fake bloody
hand was there and took a picture yeah
cuz I don't even I was like I was just
like aha and this mm-hmm and butter yeah
yeah like and that's sighs why do I go
to butter and mayonnaise though why I
don't know cuz I love butter and me
you're not a vegan yeah
you